[Music]
good spin-offs require delicate
balancing acts lean too heavily in one
direction and you stray from the source
material lean too far in the other and
you're little more than fanservice
a good spin-off takes advantage of the
world that's sprang from without being
beholden to it this is no easy task
maybe that's why the very words spin off
is often used as a pejorative
with so many offshoots of movie
franchises and television shows many
tend to fall by the cultural wayside
they're forgettable and pandering
excuses to waste time until the next
full season or blockbuster sequel arrive
but of course spin-offs can also be a
thing of beauty as long as there has
been entertainment there have been
supporting characters that draw so much
attention they break into their own
starring roles from Cheers came Frasier
from Breaking Bad came better call Saul
from Shrek came Puss in Boots nothing
will distract me
Oh video games are no strangers to the
phenomenon in fact some modern
franchises are built on their spin-off
potential some became so successful in
ubiquitous on their own you might be
surprised to learn that they even began
as spin-offs and while it hasn't
eclipsed the scope and quality of its
original source material the recent
throne breaker The Witcher tales has
earned a spot among the pantheon of
great spin-off video games
it carries CD Projekt RED or say they
project Reds world into a new genre it
tells a story from a different
perspective and it sets itself apart
from the universe that spawned it and in
doing so it has become the perfect video
game spin-off
if you played The Witcher 3 you've
probably tried your hand at Gwent the
in-universe collectible card game is
played across the northern kingdoms
pitting travelers against each other in
homes and taverns alike throne breaker
on the other hand rips Gwent from the
confines of the witcher 3 and places it
at the center of an entirely new RPG you
fill the shoes of Queen Eve ruler of
Rivia and leiria during the second
nilfgaardian invasion basically it's a
prequel to the first Witcher game it's a
reward of its own to explore the places
and meet the characters we've only heard
about in the original trilogy but throne
breaker takes things further using memes
unique perspective as Queen to tell a
story about the burden of leadership and
the difficult choices she has to make
these dilemmas are essential part of
throne breakers story between battles
the RPG places you in Sophie's Choice
scenarios that avoid the usual black and
white of simpler games
sergeant oh man a 15 summers amol will
join our ranks at once they'll serve 5
years I think perspective is a key
factor in any good spinoff better call
Saul recognized the humor and
storytelling potential in Bob Odenkirk
character and used his occupations as a
con man and a lawyer to show another
side of the justice system in the
American Southwest The Witcher 3 to use
the most recent series entry is about a
lone wanderer in a dangerous world
throne breaker shows us that same world
from a different social stratum 1 in
which Trust plays a much larger role as
Neves allegiance as sought from numerous
angles after all few people ever bowed
to Geralt of Rivia the shift and
storytelling perspective is aided of
course by a shift in gameplay as opposed
to the third-person action of its RPG
predecessors throne breaker uses the
strategy and collecting of a card game
to drive its action this fits well in a
game where you play as a leader you
travel the kingdoms recruiting new
soldiers or cards to your cause you
bolster Army's might as you fight
nilfgaard across a variety of locales
throne breaker does have problems with
difficulty spikes or in some cases a
complete lack of difficulty but more
often the rules of Gwent make for
challenging and rewarding battles throne
breaker is at its very best when it
embraces the puzzle aspects
of certain scenarios take this fight for
instance against an al Ghul in The
Witcher 3 these enemies can regenerate
their own health
forcing Geralt to stay on the offensive
in throne breaker that ability is much
more dangerous by consuming dead units
from the enemy deck the al Ghul absorbs
their health becoming stronger with each
passing turn and making the fight more
difficult the longer you take so in both
cases al Ghul's are dangerous but in
throne breaker there's a new twist on
that danger it's a microcosm for the
spinoff as a whole it takes aspects of
the universe we're familiar with and
asks us to see them through a new lens
it's important to note at this point
that I don't normally gravitate toward
collectible card games I dabbled in
hearthstone when it first released but
by and large the genre just doesn't grab
me I've always preferred the flexibility
of a turn-based tactics game to the more
rigid rules of a CCG but throne breaker
grabs me and it didn't let go I came for
The Witcher world but I stayed for the
characters and more surprisingly the
nuanced card combat it's based in a
universe I adore but it's eased me into
a genre I don't normally care for by
offering new perspectives both in terms
of story and overall genre throne
breaker pulled me out of my comfort zone
and I could not be happier about it as I
mentioned already there are numerous
flaws and throne breaker its difficulty
is all over the place its story slows to
a crawl in too many spots
it also overstays its welcome by 5 hours
or so as with every other video game
thrown breaker is not perfect but in its
function as a spin-off throne breaker is
perfect it adds to the witcher world
without retreading it it makes great use
of source material without being
hindered by it there's much more than
fanservice here but fans will find
plenty to love now that I've beaten
throne breaker I can't wait to see where
else CD Projekt can take the witcher
universe if this one is any indication
future witcher spin-offs will demand my
attention
you